russo vamos precisamente hasta londres
con toda la información que la tiene
nuestra corresponsal luisa pulido luisa
qué bueno saludarla muy buen día la
pregunta entonces los detalles que se
conocen de la visita de johnson a medio
oriente además una visita llena de
polémica no luís a
buenos días sin duda es una visita
relámpago como lo mencionas arabia
saudita y abu dhabi es altamente
controversial porque tratando de
reemplazar el petróleo y los
hidrocarburos de rusia y de asegurar
además que los precios internacionales
del petróleo no sigan creciendo para que
estos nos sigan afectando los precios de
los alimentos a nivel global el reino
unido puede hacer acuerdos con países
altamente cuestionados en sus bajos
estándares de la protección de los
derechos humanos la parada más
controversial es arabia saudita donde
johnson se reunirá con el príncipe
heredero mohamed bills al mar que han
sido acusado acusado por occidente de
ordenar directamente el asesinato del
periodista del washington post jamal
kazuki en el 2018 y este fin de semana
el pasado fin de semana por la ejecución
de al menos 81 personas y también el
papel de arabia en la guerra en yemen el
jefe del partido de la oposición el
laborista decir que estarme acusado al
gobierno de no tener una estrategia
energética y ha dicho que va de la mano
de dictador en dictador a propósito de
esta visita también será buscar que los
países del medio oriente aumenten su
protección y aumenten su producción de
petróleo ahora luisa en qué consistirá
esta nueva estrategia energética para
reino unido que finalmente lo que está
buscando johnson
sin duda no se conocen los detalles pero
lo cierto es que hay urgencia porque el
reino unido- ha anunciado que a finales
de este 2022 no se permitirán las
importaciones de petróleo y sus
derivados desde rusia el gobierno afirma
que esas importaciones rusas representan
el 8 por ciento de la demanda del reino
unido- así que se espera que esta
estrategia sea revelada la próxima
semana el primer ministro dijo desde abu
dhabi que esas posibles nuevas fuentes
de energía serán más renovables más
verdes y nucleares recordemos que el
reino unido- ha firmado el acuerdo para
cero emisiones para 2050 pero lo cierto
es que en estas alturas y con la
urgencia de reemplazar el petróleo y los
hidrocarburos que vienen de rusia no
puede quitar ninguna opción de la mesa
eso significaría que podría seguir
explorando petróleo en el mar del norte
en escocia y tampoco se descarta el
fracking